so yeah we're gonna talk about some fun
stuff or somewhat I think it's fun my
threshold for fun is pretty low
I'm Michael jolly and I'm happy to talk
about using containerized sequel server
as part of our development lifecycle so
one of the greatest things about doing
this is this is all our twitch family I
see so many twitch friends and chat it's
just this is fam right this is family
time so let's talk about it let me tell
you a little bit about my background
I've been a software developer and
architect for nearly 20 years primarily
focused on mobile and web
I'm live coding on Twitch three days a
week as part of the live coders team
with c-sharp fritz Jeff Fritz and I'm an
office hero i ambassador I love talking
about security so feel free to hit me up
on that because you know that's fun
stuff and when I'm not running code I'm
probably spending time with my family
playing music or trying to exit them
it's a losing battle so one of the best
parts of my job is to find new
technologies and tools and processes
that help people in their developer
experience and I'm excited to share one
of those with you today I've been using
it for write four or five months and it
is legit it is too legit in fact to quit
yes said that so docker we don't need no
stinking Dockers well what is docker
let's just go really quick high-level
overview you will not know all the
intricacies of docker after this but
what is it the easiest and some would
say too simplistic way to describe
docker is to compare them to virtual
machines they are not virtual machines
but both provides similar resource
isolation and allocation benefits but
they're fundamentally different because
at score doc VM that virtualize is
hardware whereas containers virtual
the OS and really that's kind of a
heavy-handed way to describe it
containers reply be better described as
a system service they're isolated and
don't really know about anything you
don't specifically tell them about for
instance they don't need to know about
networking they don't need to know about
peripherals is that a word well it is
now and so on you know it doesn't have
to know anything about that it's just a
service that's running if you need it to
have network access you tell it about
network access if it needs to know file
access you tell it about file access
well another another reason we want to
use docker is because man the containers
the images are so much smaller compared
to like a VM image or just even a whole
install of sequel server the images can
be in the tens to hundreds of megabytes
versus gigs of just the install for
sequel right nobody but sequel in a
container what are the benefits to
putting it in a container why would I
want to do that well I'll tell you why
I'm glad you asked first
is the reduced footprint on your local
machine so if you've ever installed
sequel you know that it's a big install
and then I've got to deal with updates
periodically and I don't want to I don't
want to I don't want to fight that
battle right I mean I only need sequel
server when I'm developing or maybe
having to do some kind of data
manipulation for a client something like
that you know I don't I don't
necessarily need all that stuff all the
time
second one of the benefits is we get
cross-platform support so all of our
friends on Linux and our friends on Macs
who are developing can all kind of share
in the joy that is developing against
sequel without having to you know
install that there right and the third
one is one less although massive attack
vector on our machine if you've ever
installed sequel server and watched your
era logs you know firsthand that sequel
server is one of the most attacked
pieces of software in the world it's
insane and I don't want to be exposed to
that I don't want to
think about that right so by running
sequel server in a container you get all
the benefits of a full install while
being able to throw it away when you're
done working with no impact to your
local development machine that's right
hashtag not on my machine so let's let's
well before we get it to the demos I do
want to say you probably shouldn't be
running sequel server in a container in
a production environment while only a
Sith deals in absolutes I will say it
would be a very unique use case that you
would need to run sequel in a container
in a production environment but we can
use it for day-to-day tasks and to
improve our development workflow so
let's see it in action
are you ready first I'm just gonna show
you some some code we're gonna run in
the terminal spinning it up in a
container basically we're gonna run a
command we have to have docker installed
right that makes sense and we're gonna
run that command up there that's kind of
in the teal and basically to break down
what each of those points are you're
setting two environment variables one is
the SA accounts password shoutout dotnet
comp we're also gonna accept a EULA you
just got to do it name is optional but
recommended because it names that
container that's running and in
otherwise you're gonna have to reference
that container by like the ID which is
god-awful don't do it you'll love me if
you if you'll you'll love me the minute
you do it and remember a Mike said don't
do that and then finally the - D we're
telling we're telling docker what image
we want to use to build that container
so in this case we're using MS sequel
server 2017 and it's actually running in
Linux so that's pretty cool wait let's
do that matter of fact let's go back and
let me escape out of that and why don't
we do some magic in PowerShell so let me
go we're going to run that command
trust me we're gonna run it it's gonna
be so cool okay so there's that command
I'm just copying and pasting it in hit
go-go-gadget run and there it is so it
gives me this gobbledygook and that's
that image you never want to see that
string so with that running we should
see some docker containers running so if
I well I mean not use my aliases let me
the long form it here
there's our docker container look at it
it's beautiful look at that sucker
running for 18 seconds names sequel oh
one well so let's go through a use case
right so I can tell you we have a client
who oftentimes sends us a backup of
their one of their production databases
and says hey we've made some changes we
want you to refresh the sequel database
that you have and you're developing
against to have our newest stuff so what
it'll do it what will we keep their
database in Azure so they send us a
backup well normally you can just import
a backup file to Azure but you can't
have custom security logins with that
and wouldn't you know what this client
has custom security logins because you
know customers got a customer so let's
go into that directory I've got a folder
here and I've actually got a backup
right and I'm going to let's see we've
got that container out there let's just
do this let's talk about maybe can we do
it so we've got our container running
that's what we that we we we executed
this to do it now let's talk about
copying files in and out so basically
this customer sent me a backup file and
I need to get that security login out so
I can upload it to Azure so we're gonna
run that command there with docker copy
and we're gonna copy in the first
parameter is the source file the second
parameter is the destination file and if
you're gonna use that you're gonna use a
container as one of the source or the
destination you need to prefix it like
container name or ID colon the path so
sequel one is the name of that container
I spun up so let's run that same command
and I'm going to in this sources data
folder I'm gonna copy in that backup
client gonna client dot back and I'll
come over here to my command line copy
up that to Dec container and it just
comes up now one of the cool things I
did in this when we executed the command
to started up I exposed the port that's
up here port 14 33 I told it hey in that
container you have port team 30 14 33
map that to my local hosts my host
machines 14 33 so I can come into sequel
and connect to that sequel server using
the password look in here there's no
databases we just spun it up right
there's no databases here but I can come
in and say hey restore a database
because I copied that back into the
container
I can now magically select it there and
that bet you'll notice the path VAR r ms
sequel data that it no windows path you
know okay well thank you open it up
let's say now I know they've got yep
Shawn Hasselhoff I knew they had a
custom login in there so I'm just gonna
remove him I don't need it I'm just want
to get this okay so now I need to do a
backup backup yeah yeah default stuff
yeah just do it make it so number one
okay disconnect from that so now in that
container I've got a copy of a backup
file in there that has that security
login or moved so I'm just going to let
me see let me copy that command in it's
basically the same copy command but the
parameters are back are swapped so I'm
gonna copy from the container out to my
local machine and here I've got a backup
and matter of fact if I go ahead and
delete that to show that it did it guys
you know don't want to be cheating here
there you go there's that backup from
the container that doesn't have that
security login so now I can go in there
and have fun with it so it's cool stuff
you can map drives matter of fact we can
let's see let me come in too
their slides again let's slide on up in
here yeah yeah yeah that's a little late
port forwarding and volume mapping so we
just showed you port forwarding because
we added that P 14 33 33 and that's
mapping it from the host to the inside
we can also map a volume it mop
basically mapping a drive right so in
this case I would be saying D sources
data which is a directory on my machine
map that in too far up in a cichlid data
that'll be a great way to persist that
data because once the containers are
gone let me get rid of that thing sequel
1 D sequel 1
good bye to you so now we don't have any
containers and I'm gonna run the same
command again to create a container but
this time I'm gonna tell it hey map that
D sources data which is the folder we're
in over here to that directory inside
the container which is where Microsoft
sequel server stores its data in this
container so just hit that it's gonna
execute there I've got a container you
should be running now and then look over
here in this folder all of a sudden my
master database starts showing up my
model my temp DB all those files start
showing up so now I can log back into
that again like a boss I can come in
here and create a new database yo
this is cool hit OK and I've got the
database in SSMS just like normal but
I've also got the MDF and everything
over here so now when I disconnect from
that you just get out of it I'm gonna
come over here and say you know stop
that container a matter of fact heck I
hate it so bad just delete that
container it's no longer on my machine I
don't have sequel installed on my
machine now but because I mapped that
drive I've still got the database and
the data that can use other places yes
the best table name ever and yeah I mean
[ __ ] all up in your chat reading your
messages yeah so so that's pretty cool
so
we can do everyday tasks like that but
let's take it a step further are you
ready ladies and gentlemen are you ready
let's go into visual studio because you
know developer Gunn develop so in here
I've got a very simple app it is so
simple in fact that it will amaze you
all I've got is a couple classes you
know client class what's you gonna do
it's got an A and create we're gonna use
some indie framework core right because
that's how that's how we play here and
then I've got some things you know
normally my connection streams gonna be
some environment variable super-secret
connection string but if I'm in debug
I'm gonna tell it hey the server is
called sequel demo the database is
called
oMG data and there's my username
password now of course that's just in
debug right so there's just some stuff
we're gonna we have a method to seed the
data if we need it now we got our model
this is all just EF course now if we're
not gonna get into that but trust me
it's amazing and then we have one
database migration that basically builds
out the database with the clients and
the and the address table and then I've
got this like web app this dotnet core
MVC or asp net core MVC app and all it's
doing is spinning up and in that home
controller I get that context from that
thing
pull in the clients and return it to the
index view in the index view just
basically does a TR builds a table with
the ID and the name now my C data method
is running every time in my startup I've
got it telling it hey OMG context
migrate that data police so that we have
it so then when I run it nothing's gonna
happen it's gonna bomb because it's
gonna say that database doesn't exist
except I have a docker file here because
of course I'm gonna eventually deployed
this asp net core app in a docker
container so I've got a docker composed
and that docker compose I say spin up
that doc sequel docker web app and call
it sequel docker web you know and then
it depends on this sequel demo service
which is basically the sequel 2017 we're
call it sequel demo and because it's in
that docker container it's going to put
those on the same network just amongst
themselves I've exposed the port here so
that I can access it with SMS if I
wanted to and then I've also mapped that
drive so that we can see the data later
on so that container was gone so I can
delete those files and I'm gonna debug
this web app and if all of the demo gods
have been sufficient sufficiently
appeased today we should see a browser
open up and magically it'll be just the
default asp net website except it should
list one client so let's see database
method basically sees one client in one
address and right now it's starting up
it's compiling it all it's gonna spin up
an asp net core container and it's gonna
spin up a sequel server and there it is
look at that I've got one record with
just the ID that's a grid that the
customers name and when I get done I can
close this thing down and stop debugging
get out of it all I can go delete
containers now look at that it created
my oMG data database so I've still got
that that I can play with if I need to I
can access it I can spin up that
container and connect to it through SMS
if I wanted to
matter of fact heck let's do it why not
do it live let that thing start back up
we'll connect to that sucker like a boss
let's see we want to connect we're gonna
have to wait for it to finish loading
okay I got my web app up so proof in the
pudding the web app is running so the
sequel server should be running ah OMG
data OMG data there's my clients my
addresses it's got the migration history
because you know that's how we roll with
EF core in that awesome I've got my data
there I can sample it an SSD bugging I
think there's something wrong with the
data I can still play with it and I can
close it down so this is like
legit just a database for me and my
development environment and when I'm
done with it I can say get out of here
sequel and they're not on my machine
because I named it I can just say doctor
why don't you remove sequel demo and
sequel docker dot web because I'm done
oh I had to stop them d CX sequel demo I
apologize for the d CX that's an alias
which you can get from the dev toolbox
PowerShell extension it's pretty cool
and it also works better if you type the
names right justice you know little
helper there for you if he's type the
name of the container right
it always removes it better so now I'm
done with Visual Studio I'm done
developing but because I mapped that
drive I've still got my data there if I
want to use it or if I didn't map it it
could just go away too which is
wonderful
it makes everybody happy if you're not
happy with that well I don't know what
to tell you call Mark Miller because
that presentation was amazing
so with that thanks everybody for
listening to me talk about this it's
it's always fun to hang out with all of
you my friends on Twitch and the
interwebs this is the Michael John
that's right Bobby Johnson you can find
my slides the the code that I use some
additional links to help you start doing
this at that bitly link there well you
can find me on twitter at michael jolly
I know it sounds weird but you can also
find me on the web at Michael jolly calm
I know it's hard to remember and then of
course I'm streaming 3 days a week on
Twitch I'd love to see you there
and hang out with you and and that's it
yeah anybody got some questions yes cuz
I've got answers we've got some I can't
hear me okay
I can't hear sweet so there we go so
yeah we have some questions that people
been posting people mostly having issues
with oh there you go perfect thank you
for turning the camera on and off that
was perfect
that's how we do it in developer land
that's right and off so
with regards to a hey EF and whatever
else but the one that's here that I
think it's gonna drive some good
conversation is molten MC backers asking
why wouldn't you use docker and sequel
server in a production environment why
is that an issue because okay so so
think of docker as like a a service
right a system service that's running if
you have like a little process web app
something very specific like that
perfect for that scenario you wouldn't
want to try you know think about like
micro services really right but you
wouldn't go put s ap in a container it's
just too much I mean you're gonna you're
gonna you're gonna shoot yourself to be
honest you're you're not gonna last a
year you're gonna drive yourself crazy
same way with sequel server it's a
little too big and then you get into
issues of scaling that right for
instance like I showed you how to mount
a drive to like the host machine for the
data so that data persists well that
will be the only way to do it because
the containers transient it goes away
and comes back and come goes away and
comes back well if you don't mount that
to a drive to data is gonna go away with
the container that is bad news if you're
running in production but if you did
mount it and you tried to scale that
sequel instance you're gonna have issues
because you can't mount all those
containers pointing to that same data
file and and live if things are gonna go
squirrely real quick when all those
containers are trying to access the same
MDF yep but it's perfect in these little
small scenarios where you have just some
tasks to run where I don't have to deal
with like the full big install I don't
have to deal with managing updates and
all that kind of stuff and firewall
settings to make sure I'm not being
attacked matter of fact if you don't
forward the ports to your host machine
like I showed you
there's no exposure at all I was totally
available in that little docker network
it's really cool perfect yeah I was just
I was looking at the chat here and
Moulton backers says like good cool good
to know thank you for answering my
question but that was really great
good good you everybody don't you
everybody loved the presentation you did
an awesome job I knew you I knew you
would but it's in our tech check a
couple days ago so thank you again
Michael for taking the time to chat with
us and share your knowledge and your
passion
absolutely your humor with us what night
were you funny
now I'm kidding okay so we are gonna for
everybody watching the stream we're
gonna get Michael off the the Skype here
and get Sui ki who is our next presenter
we're gonna talking about mixed reality
and xamarin no that's so we are gonna be
doing that here so we're going straight
into the slate and going mute for a
little bit we'll talk to you guys in a
little bit are you